hey everybody welcome to episode 5 of
the 13 o'clock podcast today we are
doing kind of an eerie espionage theme
spot [ __ ] jokey spy [ __ ] yep I'm gonna
sit here vaping or long for the ride so
we have like kind of a bunch of well
really three topics that are sort of
sort of related yeah and the first thing
we wanted to talk about we're gonna do
some like weird creepy like possibly
spy-related unsolved murders like after
you know later in the show but the first
thing we're gonna talk about is numbers
station yeah yeah you hear a lot of
stuff about number stations like on
YouTube and other YouTube channels if
you read the comments a lot of people
kind of reading into what a numbers
channel is or what a number station is
but I actually kind of have some
personal experience with encoding and
decoding when I was in the military but
go ahead yeah tell my number station is
well the thing is I think the reason
that people are so fascinated by them is
they're so creepy I'm gonna think
they're creepy sounding some of them are
really creepy sounding and actually we
have I have a few examples of them that
I'm gonna put in here yeah sure what are
numbers the wooden number but yeah you
okay yeah sure right you show a few of
them alright so so we're gonna pause for
a second and I'll play you a couple of
examples of them oh and these are shout
out to the conet project on archive.org
he has like a hundred and fifty of these
different ones if you want to go listen
to it I'll put a link you know in the
show notes sometimes collects these
things yeah because they're fascinating
and some of them are super weird so okay
so here's a few examples so listen to a
few examples of these super super creepy
okay
Oh
okay and that's that yeah yeah so and
and I specifically picked like super
creepy because I think even though I
know what they are yeah they're still
creepy sounding I kind of know how they
work
yeah yeah I mean basically the history
of I mean you can look it up on
Wikipedia and it'll kind of tell you
more about all this kind of stuff
they basically think they started in
World War one and there are I mean they
have them for pretty much everywhere and
actually I think some of them are still
going yeah they're basically it's
basically thought that it's it's
governments or it's like you know
sometimes fishing industries and yeah
they're giving encoded information to
specific to specific people yeah
specific could be foreign agents yeah
you know it could be anything like that
and there are there actually are a
couple of famous ones probably the most
famous one is the Lincolnshire poacher
yeah which came out of the UK which i
think is defunct now but that was 60s
yeah well actually that went on for a
really long time in the eighties
actually I have to check
that's Cold War stuff yeah that's kind
of Cold War stuff they called it that
because that the tone that would alert
the yeah that would alert the person was
the folk song the Lincolnshire poacher
like two bars of it and you know there's
other kind of famous ones like Russian
man and stuff like that like I said if
you go on the conet project on
archive.org he's got like a whole [ __ ]
ton of them but so tom here was in the
army
yeah oh I
I did I did several different jobs in
the army and one of the things that I
did was I was an infantry scout for the
first in the 37th infantry infantry
battalion and as a scout
we carry radios and we carried a
primitive vietnam-era radio called the
PRC PRC 77 which was really super
low-tech and there were way there was
ways to encrypt your messages but any
kind of mechanical or computerized
encryption can eventually be cracked the
best way to encode something is to
encode something and are using a real
primitive encryption method now when you
hear when you hear in those ring tones
and uh on a number station that could
mean a couple of different things it's
all it's all pre-arranged between the
sender is kind of like the
communications officer and the person
who is to receive it let's say it's an
agent the ring tones could mean well it
each one's gonna be different each
number station will be different every
company every organization that does
this is going to have a slightly
different way of doing it and that adds
to the security so this is not a cookie
cutter method but you can send a
ringtone usually just to let the agents
know that yes it is the sender that you
think it is so in other words this is
how they do it they will take an agent
they say we're gonna send dude let's say
Cuba okay and you're gonna be a spy we
can't send you there with a secret radio
because if they find you with that radio
they'll know you were a spy and we can't
send you there with a codebook because
then they'll know you're a spy so what
we're gonna do is we're gonna send you
there with a book on birds or a book on
it might even just be the Bible it could
be that simple and then every day at
let's say three o'clock we're gonna send
a transmission alright you will
recognize us by the ringtone and the
the frequency where this is the
frequency check us on you know 144
Earth's I don't know how that part of it
works so he dials in he hears the
ringtone at three o'clock in the
afternoon and it's gonna be a long
series of numbers now the series of
numbers gonna be gonna come in packets
it may be a packet of four it might be a
packet of five numbers like 1 3 - 9 -
that's five numbers and then it repeats
another one seven six two nine three
well though that packet of numbers is
usually a coordinate inside the book
they gave you it's a they told you it
might be chapter one okay third page
fourth paragraph second line third word
to the right and that points to a word
network might be the or it might be ant
or it might be boxcar it could be
anything okay so they're gonna give you
long streams of numbers so three o'clock
you write all the numbers down and then
you go to your book and you try to find
all the words the coordinates of all
those words now the transmission block
that they send you is always going to be
exactly the same length that way there's
no way to decode it like you don't the
person who's listening to it doesn't
know if it's a long message or a short
message or whatever every message is
exactly the same length so when the guy
goes to translate it it might be
gobbledygook and then halfway down
through the packet a sentence appears
and then after that more gobbly [ __ ] now
the random gobbly [ __ ] there may be
encoded messages messages still in there
okay it's just that it's - for another
agent working in the scenes now for that
guy it's not for that guy so the other
agent might he may have been given a
different book it might be an
instruction manual it could be anything
something that you will never know that
that's a codebook he might have a book
on helicopters so each agent gets only
the message that were intended for him
all right
and that way if one agent is captured he
can't spill the beans he has no idea of
what the other agents are talking about
what their mission is and there's no way
under interrogation to find these other
guys or find out what's happening you
know they've been in their country and
espionage why wise so it's a one-way
transmission is just sending an agent a
packet a message packet of information
now if the packet of information runs
too short they just fill it with gobbly
[ __ ] now I told you that that agent is
waiting for three o'clock to hear the
message right the thing is is that the
radio traffic is always the same that
radio station will broadcast a message
every hour on the hour or every three
hours it's going to be preset yeah that
way the enemy does not hear any decrease
or increase in radio traffic right are
we consistent it's consistent right that
way they can't sit there and wait and
hear a transmission maybe there hasn't
been a transmission in three days and
then the enemy gives a transmission the
way that something's happening [ __ ] I'm
gonna raise the alert you know right or
they might say why is it whenever we
move our nuclear material a transmission
happens we've been infiltrated so that's
why so it's constant barrage of messages
now the other message is on other hours
they may have information in them too
but they may be for other agents right
not you as a single agent in this
country right so there could be a
constant stream of information and
updates yeah but each each agent is
probably only given one maybe two
windows to listen for in a day right I
think I explained that crisis and really
and didn't you say that done correctly
it's essentially an unbreakable code
unbreakable because no one knows there's
no code that can be cracked because it's
not a digital code it's an analog code
and the agents have been primed and
instructed in person orally by the the
controller right and there
no codebook it's just a random loss to
random yet might be the Bible it might
be an instructions on how to fix a
tractor
yeah and be anything and if that guy
ever gets captured there's no way of
knowing that he's an agent and that he
has a code book there's no code book
right there gonna turn a book into a
code book yeah which is actually pretty
[ __ ] genius what do you think yeah
and and the key to crack that code is in
the head of that particular agent and he
can only crack the messages that were
intended for hit were intended for him
yeah he so he has no code no use while
no useful code to crack any other
messages that's so cool yeah it's still
spooky though yeah they still sounds and
it's foolproof and yeah and it's like
something out of a video game fallout
it's real you can you can do it at the
end of the end of the world in an
apocalyptic event as long as you have a
radio transmitter powerful enough you
can get a secret message to somebody
yeah yeah that's pretty cool and some of
them they call them all number stations
but some of them actually don't use
numbers some of them use like encoded
tones or there's one called backwards
music but it's actually not backwards
music it's some kind of encoded tones
yeah it could be several different
things they may be numbers yeah but then
the numbers are Scrabble are scrambled
either squares they're Scrabble by the
electronic scrambler okay but that would
require the agent to have some kind of
an electronic device to scratch to
descramble them then that made that like
that electronic device may be inside of
an embassy because a lot of these
messages are actually if you were to
trace the source come from an embassy
there's an embassy communications
intelligence officer who would if the
u.s. if it was an American station be
CIA dad alright if it was an old Soviet
one it would be KGB right now the the
guy who sent in the messages he may be
in a an embassy or consulate and they
may transmit from that consulate but a
lot of times not they're gonna transmit
from a remote antenna maybe from a ship
maybe from somewhere else there's they
have ways and to doll spook craft yeah
right it's bullcrap but most of it most
of the radio stations I think we're well
to be on certain frequencies and spies
the spy agencies didn't bother jamming
them because if you jam their signals
they will jam yours
so you'll lose you lose contact with all
your agents right so there's cotton
there was kind of a gentlemen's
agreements between the in the
intelligence communities that lists all
talk yeah basically it's better that we
all talk instead of none of us talking
to our agents so they just let it go oh
now most of the message is very
civilized yeah well they have to do
their jobs oh yeah all right and what's
funny though is that a lot of the
messages if you were to probably encode
or decode them or even if you were to
decode them they're probably not too
exciting well yeah I mean usually well
it wouldn't it just be something like
hey you go to this place at this time or
do this and that it might be something
along the lines of keep trying you know
stuff like that it's mission complete
yet return to base missions over things
like that probably very rarely you get
that hey bump off this dude no I'm very
hurt most of the time they're talking to
guys who are civilians that have been
taken into the CIA right these civilians
might work in industries and they're
working in an industry inside of a
foreign company inside of a foreign
company in another place right and they
may be talking about a dinner party
that's happened in that night because
that agent was trying to find out you
know some detail about some technology
or something about the stock market
there's no telling it could be anything
it could be anything it could be about
recruiting a foreign national into the
intelligence group to bribe him to get a
secret something like that yeah it's
gonna be it's gonna depend on each
situation yeah but you know like I said
it's it's actually a really interesting
topic I mean I think a lot of people
kind of know about it now because I
think they made that movie a couple
years ago called the number station that
was kind of about that onec and yeah I
didn't see any there but I think John
Cusack was in it and and actually the
funny thing is that sometimes it
number stations are broadcasting on
random frequencies sometimes they turn
up like in places where they're not
supposed to be like they'll they'll
actually accidentally like broadcast on
a frequency that a lot of people hear
like I think one time the BBC like had
wrote it there one of their ones kind of
bleeding into the frequency and people
were calling to complain what are all
these numbers somebody's talking numbers
over my TV show that that's that's one
of the controllers saying look I'm gonna
send you a message it's gonna be on this
frequency it'll be tomorrow or next week
on a Thursday at 3 o'clock in the
morning you know and you know then they
send it so something Priya raged like I
meant to receive it was listening on
that channel waiting for it to appear
maybe they didn't check whether or not
that channel that's what yeah that's
what they were saying like sometimes
they don't they just pick a random
frickin Tran sometimes right like I said
sometimes it's the BBC well it seems
random to the outside world but it
wasn't random to the guys who were sent
in and receiving it right but yeah so
that that's what hats outnumber stations
work Madsen it's not always my
understanding is it's not always
intelligence agencies it can also be
like commercial fishing groups they're
trying to contact another one of their
boats hey the fish will over here get
over here and they don't want other they
don't want to know about it because then
everybody then everybody goes there yeah
I think we should start communicating
like that well the fishing in caves you
gotta understand a lot of these
commercial fishermen and anybody on the
sea lot of them have Navy naval
background yeah they learned that kind
of stuff when they were in the Navy so
yeah those tricks that's pretty awesome
army infantry used those tricks now I
think a clock I hate X cellphones cuz
they're real hard yeah I don't yeah I
kind of wonder if they I mean like I
said some of they like bleed throughs
have happened happened in like the 2000s
so apparently some of them are still
broadcasting
but that's Intelligence Agency yes so
that's gonna be see the problem with the
problem with using encode decode like we
used in the army back back in the 90s
the problem with that is that it's slow
yeah so if you're taking fire from the
enemy and you're sure you don't really
have time to like intro
can be like you can't code cuz you had a
book called the SOR being shot at
[ __ ] we don't write time for so a lot
of that stuff had to just be had to be
transmitted kind of unsecure maybe it
was slightly scrambled but the enemy has
descrambler
yeah but the problem but the difference
is is that in an infantry unit 90% of
the stuff that you're saying over the
radio
if the enemy heard it it's not gonna
help them it's not gonna it's not gonna
change the fact that you're whipping
their ass none of its really secret it's
just but the CIA and intelligence works
that's different right because the
information in there you could foil the
plans it's not it's not usually
involving gunplay yeah they'll just
arrest arrests or whoever it is you're
trying to bribe right and they don't
want they don't want the enemy to know
okay gotcha
but yeah it looks like from when I was
looking up on Wikipedia when I was doing
research they said that actually this
year two months ago actually in July
2016 north Korea has revived their
number broadcasts oh yeah after a hiatus
of 16 years yeah they've got agents
somewhere yeah now I'm sure yeah I don't
know how it's a one-way communication
you're just sending the answers to them
I don't know how the message gets how
responses come back it could may be
physical in some cases they may have a
physical person that that person can
respond to in other words you know
somebody working back at the Embassy
they just go back to the embassy and
answer basically it could
I've heard of stuff like them placing
ads and newspapers that are encoded
phrases that can be decoded yeah yeah
I've heard about that kind of thing but
in the modern age is probably something
done on a computer yeah probably you
sent a text message that looks very
innocuous it looks like you sent it to
your mom or something like that but
actually it's not it was an encoded text
message to your handler you would think
though I mean I was saying you know the
whole radio thing and the and the
codebook kind of stuff
it seems very low-tech but in a lot of
ways it seems
better it's better it's impossible to
crack yeah because like I said crack it
right and like I said you know sending
messages over you know over the Internet
over Wi-Fi things like that it's really
not probably not safe in any capacity
even if it's scrambled even if it's
encoded right someone somewhere could
break that well when you could you could
do it over the internet the same way you
do it with the number stations in other
words yeah it's it's a it's a sentence
right or a paragraph and you read it and
a paragraph has nothing to do with
anything but the person who's receiving
it might know that through a certain
code algorithm every fourth letter out
of there can be combined in other words
every fourth letter in the entire
paragraph can be combined to read
something
Laska I'm talking about as a hidden
message inside of it and it's not
something that a computer can figure out
it's something that somebody with a
mental key in their head could figure
out yeah although they have some pretty
good AI computers maybe they could crack
that but the time that you would need to
crack a lot of this stuff the
information is worthless by the time you
figure it out and the codes gonna change
each time like for instance when I said
that the the set of numbers might point
give you the coordinates in a specific
book to the word the correct yeah well
they're not going to be pointing to the
same though each time right I got you
you know Tommy yeah the falls on many
different coordinates yeah
the person who is encoding it is just
going through the book going where's a
UH
oh there's one writing it down right
yeah weird it's done okay where's where
does it work Brown there's one and just
writes that down well Brown in that book
might be mentioned two six times
right you don't know yeah okay but uh
okay so what's what I'm gonna do now
because we're coming up on 21 something
20 minutes I actually want to play a few
more examples for the listeners okay and
then we will take a break and then we're
gonna come back and I'm gonna talk about
two really creepy unsolved murders yeah
you briefly told me about these then
yeah that we're probably spies I mean
you know I don't know what else they
could have been and actually the first
one I'm going to talk about
actually also involves code okay with
the book so and some of y'all might know
what I'm talking about because it's it's
kind of well-known the second one I'm
talking about is not so well known so
we're gonna pause right now and I'm
going to play some more number of
stations and then we're going to take a
break and then we'll be back
Oh
or bring that for
you're a nine
bring him
Oh
Oh
four to three set for
zero a nine
bring 74 1 1
where is nine second arrow
four zero two six seven
we're nearly to sex Oh
nine four six seven four
for now a 12-0
six two four three
four thousand eight seven nine
oh that 0a Nam
my way 101
by your old one now
five seven four nine nine
mara bring a one
nine seven six six five
one six nine six
nine nine six seven seven
a zero thousand a
one day a year our grave
Oh or 1 9 8
nine to a one
I say again
bring for them 4 1 1 6 3 9 6 0 4 1 9 8
nine three eight one gray
I would like to take a second and thank
subculture corsets in clothing for
sponsoring project I radio and my show
while listening to my podcast please
take a second and visit their website at
www.att.com/biz
recover lega fix seem Punk and pin up
clothing shoes and accessories again
their website is subculture corsets calm
or if you're in the jacksonville florida
area stop by their store in The Avenues
Mall and if you like to save money use
the discount code 13 o'clock when
checking out and save 10% off your
entire order by the way if you're a
curvy girl subculture do not forget
about you they carry size 4 to 4 X and
guys they have men's clothing and shoes
as well so go shop at subculture corsets
calm now and use the discount code 13
o'clock for a 10% discount ok and we're
back so the first thing actually I was
going to talk about the less well-known
case first but I think I'm gonna do this
one first because we were talking about
codes and this one has to do with a code
ok now those of you who follow weird
[ __ ] kind of lore have probably heard of
the Somerton man also known as the
thames shoed case if i'm pronouncing
that correctly i think its persian this
happened in 1948 in december in
australia now there was a man found in
Somerton it's a small beach town and he
was found dead leaned up against a wall
on the beach he there were no signs of
struggle there were no signs of what's
the word I'm looking for like he didn't
look like he'd been beat up he didn't
look like he wasn't stabbed or shot no
injuries um he had no identification no
wallet no wedding ring no name tags no
nothing all of the labels had been cut
out of his clothing when they and
actually here was the weird thing they
didn't know if they thought maybe he had
been dumped there because
later when they did the autopsy they
found out that all that his stomach and
his brain and his spleen I think were
blood and gorged which would indicate
some type of poisoning yeah but where he
was laying on the sand there was no
vomit there was no sign of that he'd
been kicking around or that he was in
pain or I think is usually poisoning is
very painful death okay I'm telling you
right I can tell you right now he wasn't
killed in that location he was dumped in
that well now see that's the next thing
I was gonna say so that's the first
thing that police thought was that he
was dumped there
but people witnesses the night before
had seen him laying there and had seen
him moving so he was not dead yet and a
coroner said that he hadn't died until
2:00 a.m. and people had seen him like
the previous evening like 6 or 7 o'clock
like people had been walking down the
beach and they saw him laying there and
they just thought he was drunk or
sleeping it off but they said that one
of them said yeah he moved his arm and
he looked like he was moving around or
he was in a different position when they
found him so like I said no idea you
know nothing all they found on him they
found a bus ticket from a town call
called Glenelg which was another town
that wasn't that far away and you know
they thought that he had come you know
on that bus from from there they found a
pack of cigarettes some gum a comb that
had been made in America and some
matches he also had a cigarette tucked
behind one ear and a partially smoked
cigarette caught in between his cheek
and his shoulder as if he'd been smoking
it when he died well Australian stuff
that he had no it was not and here's
another thing ok now here was here was
the creepiest [ __ ] when they you know
they took him away and started examining
the body and they started examining his
clothes in his pants they found like a
little secret pocket that they hadn't
seen before in that pocket was a little
piece of rolled up paper and that paper
had two words on it and the words were
Tim em shoot ok now
they discovered that it's actually it
was actually the last page of you you
know the well-known book of Persian
poetry called the Rubaiyat of Omar
Khayyam and Tom I'm Jude means it is
finished or the end hmm and it was the
last book the last page of the book okay
so they found that in his pocket now so
here's the here's the thing when they
were doing the autopsy said the guy
looked like he was about in his 40s very
good physical shape but not a laborer
his hands did not look like a laborers
hand and then they said actually his
feet looked like he might have been a
dancer right and they said all the tags
on his clothes have been removed I don't
hide the country of origin where the
clothes were made
yeah but they did find out later now
when they did the the poisoning here
they found out they said they said were
pretty sure it's poisoning it wasn't one
that turned up in any of their I mean
this was 1948 they didn't have all the
same but but it wasn't like a common
poison they said it wasn't they couldn't
find any trace of it in a system or in
the food that they found in his stomach
they think that it might have been
digitalis
what's that or it's it's from I believe
it's from isn't it from some kind of
orchid I want to say that might be
totally wrong just don't yell at me but
might have been digitalis or another one
called and I don't know if I'm
pronouncing it right I think it's called
Luo Bane which comes from an African
plant and they usually use it on air for
arrow poison huh so they think that that
maybe that's what it is now because
there was no identification
they made a plaster cast of his face and
his head and you know showed it around
they took pictures of it put in the
paper all this other stuff now initially
some people came forward and said hey
this is so-and-so but none of that
panned out it's like 1 1 1 they said oh
it's this guy and then that guy turned
up at the police stations like I know
I'm alive but you know what I mean so
so they okay so here was another thing
now when they I think a year after they
found the body there's no one identified
him right and no one identified him so a
year after they found the body they
found an unclaimed suitcase in the bus
station okay which is a year later yeah
which they think belonged to him because
in the suitcase there was a little card
with this weird orange waxed thread and
that thread was not made in Australia
and it had also been used to sew up a
pocket in what in his coat so they
assumed that this was his suitcase now
in the suitcase there were a bunch of
clothes all of which had the tags
removed also there was a shank made from
a kitchen knife there was a pair of
scissors that were sharpened there was a
stencil brush which actually I saw
there's a documentary on YouTube from
1978 about this case and the guy that
the the suitcase has now been destroyed
lost because the case was so long ago
but they still had it in 1978 and they
showed it in this and that guy took
everything out and this guy said that he
thought that this guy must have been
Officer third class military Navy maybe
because he said they were issued these
stencil brushes because they're one of
their jobs was suspense all the cargo
cases because this was a particularly I
guess so that was in there and there was
a pair of pants with sand in the cuffs
there was a tie with the name T Keane
written in marker on the back of it but
there was no missing person that
corresponded to that so they don't know
if that was a fake name and also they
found out from the stitching on the
clothing that was in the suitcase the
guy was probably American because they
said that a lot of the stitching in the
coats only the United States had that
particular type of feather stitching at
the time so they thought he might have
been American okay now so
you know they found just other regular
[ __ ] in there and stuff like that but
mmm now about a year and a half later a
doctor came forward from Glenelg which
they think was the town that this guy
came from on the bus because he was
found in Somerton like I said and he
said that he had had he had found his
car in a in the parking lot and the
window had been open and he found a copy
of the Rubaiyat of Omar Khayyam in the
backseat of his car is if someone had
thrown it in the open window and its
last page was missing hmm and it was a
first edition it was a rare one it was
like from 1859 or something like that it
had been printed in New Zealand and so
the cops matched up you know the time
I'm shooed they matched that to the last
page also in this book was a code or
what looked like a code it looked like
it was just it's like five lines there's
a picture of it you can google it
there's a picture of it and it's five
lines and it's just a bunch of random
letters yeah and some people think it's
a code no one has been able to crack it
there there is I think there's a couple
of graduate students in Australia that
are working on crack in it in Australia
there's also a reddit thread which I can
link to where some people I don't know
much about code breaking then I'd be
able to crack it because the key to that
code was a word that he had in his head
see that's what some people were saying
they're saying now if this was that kind
of code then they're never going to be
able like on my number stations right so
yeah that that might be the other thing
so you know there's picture of the code
now you may think that this is as weird
as this case gets however it is not in
the book along with the code there was
also a phone number when they called
this phone number they found that it was
this woman a nurse who lived right near
where the body was found
now she she said that at one time she
had owned a copy of the Rubaiyat she had
given it to a man what was his name
called
Alfre I think his name
Alfred Boxall okay good night this was
in 1945 three years before the Somerton
man's body was found
okay now Alfred Boxall was in the
Australian Army and she had been I think
she had been having an affair with this
dude mm-hm and she gave him her copy of
the rubia now they tracked down that at
first they thought the Somerton man oh
it's Alfred Boxall except that dude was
still alive - okay and he still had his
copy of the Rubaiyat and it still had
its last page
so are you guys confused yet cuz I am
alright so now the nurse they actually
didn't identify her until 2002 I believe
her name was Jessica Thompson
I think her maiden name was Powell but
she was she was married at the time and
I think like I said she was having an
affair with this with this Boxall fella
so the here's the weird thing this
didn't now she died in 2007 she had a
couple of kids including a son named
Robin all right now the son Robin had a
very particular genetic thing with his
ear cuz apparently I didn't know this
but ears could be used like fingerprints
they're like super distinctive and
everything he had a weird thing with his
ear and a weird thing with his incisors
which didn't develop like a genetic
thing these two very rare genetic
mutations were also evident on the
plaster cast they had made of the dead
dude huh one to two percent of the
population have these two and they said
the the odds of that kid having these
exact same two genetic anomalies so
maybe that was his son that's what
that's what they're thinking
right so how the nurse is involved like
apparently like she's dead now but her
kids are still alive and I think that
her daughter said that her mother knew
who's Somerton man was but she never
said so I don't know if she killed the
dude if this
offered Boxall dude if that guy was
pretending to be him mm-hmm now she was
called in in the fort in 1948 or 1949 or
whatever to look at the plaster cast and
she told the coroner that she didn't
know who it was but the coroner said
that she reacted very strongly when she
saw it but they she said I don't know
that dude so I mean that's only his word
to go on but it was his opinion that she
did know who it was and she just said
she didn't know who I was weird so like
I said this case is super super weird
and it's actually super well known and
in Australia in the past few years like
I said they've been trying to crack the
code that was in the book if indeed it's
able to be correct and they also wanted
to get the man's body exhumed right
because for DNA analysis and whatnot now
if like if he was the father of that
nurses kids it's like what would that
mean specifically now that the kids of
Jessica said that their mom was a
Russian spy yeah that's what I was
thinking she must have been a spy so but
I don't know like how so I'm kind of
what they call wet work went down
whereas spies were in a relationship
with each other some and one had to
knock the other one off oh yeah American
KGB and CIA going at it and it looks
like it looks like some kind of civilian
murder but no yeah it was something
about we're you know because
traditionally female spies that they
were very good oh yeah and asked the
North Koreans they say they're best
spies inside Korea North Korea are women
yeah and it's because you can well
moment woman can sleep with a guy and
then find out everything about it well
and women are not perceived as
threatening also you had a lot of cases
but she was sleeping with him had his
kid but was still spying and for some
reason ended up killing him he may have
figured out that she was an enemy spy he
may have been there to kill her
you don't know wouldn't that mean
and so and maybe she poisoned him
somehow or she called other spies
Soviets five friends and they killed him
yeah it's probably what I wonder how the
poison was administered probably made
him swallow it
yeah tricked him into swallowing it and
it wasn't like I said it wasn't a common
poison it was a very unusual poison and
it was one in 1948 that didn't come up
on any test the only reason they
suspected it was poisoning at first was
because of the weird the way the blood
wasn't gorged and usually they're
usually not going to use force they're
just gonna use trickery yeah
tricked him into drinking something or
eating something to have that in it yeah
and there's also three years before the
Somerton man was found dead there was
another murder in Sydney and the victim
had a copy of the Ruby at on his chest
so they're wondering if they'll use that
as a code book right if that book was
used as a code book yeah and that ties
in really good with the first half of
the show that's what happened she had
more than one copy of the robot I'm
using that to using that book to
communicate with their operatives and
and the odd thing about this book that
they found on this guy's chest was they
said in its you know in its where it's
printed like what Edition it is yeah
there's a publisher called metha when in
London and they had published five
editions of it except this one that they
found was metha one seventh edition
which wasn't supposed to exist hmm
because they only did five so they don't
know if maybe there's a Russian copy of
the book yeah by de Ben or they don't
know if there were like particular
editions that were only used as code
books because if you're going to use a
book as a code book everyone has to have
the same Edition because different
editions are different or paginate and
different the typesetting is different
so the page numbers might not be the
same like all the words might not be on
the same page or what-have-you
so so they think maybe that was I have a
feeling that he was probably an American
guy like you said but he he may have
been also been a Russian spy might have
been a double agent might have been
might have been CIA and KGB at the same
time yeah maybe he was gonna defect to
Russia to the Russian side maybe CIA
found out about it maybe they maybe to
see how a that killed him it may have
not been KGB
yeah no way of knowing yeah there's not
enough information in no way of knowing
yeah and there's no way of knowing if
you don't even know who he was he's not
yes still don't he's definitely somebody
in the intelligence agencies one of the
two he's got to be because you're what
the [ __ ] else right
and nobody's reporting him dead or
missing right yeah no one identified him
right I mean people I know
yeah means they know who he is
identified him but but that wasn't KGB
knew who he was
but he's probably a bad guy haha
cuz they don't know I can't they
normally don't kill each other yeah
unless they have to what's something
really shitty yeah yeah and then she
covered for his death and she had his
kid so he might have been a bad guy yeah
because I mean there's a there's pretty
much no way that that her son was not
his kid because they said that the
chances against that happening would be
astronomical because he had the exact
same - it was it what it was was like
the top of his ear was like smaller than
the bottom of his ear and his incisors
were not developed it's hypo Donna or
something like that she knew he was only
Chevrolet shouldn't have that she knew
who he was but she couldn't say anything
because it wouldn't help him and it
might hurt her and her kids so yeah so
she just said it was part of the
business I don't know but uh yeah they
have pictures of it I'm actually the
where I got where the most information
about this case is that I found I mean
yeah there's a Wikipedia page and
there's you know on various unsolved
mysteries cases and stuff like that but
there's one called sword and scale site
and they have like kind of the most
comprehensive rundown of it and so I
think you know the case is actually
still ongoing like I said they're trying
to get the guy exhumed and that's not
really going anywhere people are still
trying to crack the code and actually in
2011 evidently
a woman who lived in Adelaide which you
know with that which was that area of
Australia she produced an ID card with a
picture on it and the ID card did look
the picture looked a lot like the dude
in the plaster cast the guy's name was
HC Reynolds and it was u.s. ID card
which was normally given to foreign
seamen during World War two
they said his face looked very similar
and this ID card was traced to was
issued in 1918 when HC Reynolds was 18
years old and they said that would have
made the time line about right because
when they found him he would have been
in his 40s in 1948 a lot of intelligence
guys come from navies yeah but they said
the weird thing is that they that you
know they traced that particular idea
when it was issued but no further
records of that man were found no in the
US UK or in Australia whoever he
belonged to he was erased yeah and you
know I imagine if he was Russian or
American who knows his existence would
have been erased from history they'll
never those intelligence agencies don't
know him if you were to try to get truth
out of him they wouldn't know because
they probably erased all records of him
it looks like they did if indeed that's
who it is I mean the only reason they
found this ID card was because a woman
had it
like [ __ ] in her attic or something like
that just because the guy's an American
doesn't mean that he isn't a Russian spy
just because a guy who is a Russian
doesn't mean he isn't an American spy
well yeah they work for both free either
side yeah they can be double agents
something like that or both yeah I think
more triple agents yeah or what have you
they'll just sell information he sold
information that killed him something
like that yeah but like it's a
fascinating case there's there's a
couple of documentaries about it there
was one from 1978 which in which they
show the original suitcase and all the
stuff in it which has since been
destroyed if you want to see that and
also there's a newer one about the kids
that are trying to grad students kids
I'm old I call everybody kids now but
about the grad students that are trying
to crack the code and there's
also a reddit thread where they're
trying to crack the code also if you're
kind of interested in the story and you
want to see kind of a fictionalization
of it the Stephen King book the Colorado
kid was loosely based on it and they
made a TV show called Haven from that
which is also kind of based on it now
the next murder kind of had some similar
aspects to Somerton man and this chick
was probably also a spy I want to say
she's best known as the is doll woman
because she was found in the is dalan
Valley in Norway this happened in 1970
now this woman was found it was November
1970 and it was a hiker and two
daughters they were hiking through the
is Dahlan valley which is actually
called Death Valley because of all the
skiers that died there which is nice and
they came across the remains of a
campsite and in the fire there was a
woman's body move which was partially
burned and there was also a big bruise
on her neck
scattered around the body were several
pink sleeping pills 50 of them to be
precise there was an empty bottle of
liquor a silver spoon with the monogram
filed off a packed lunch some of them
say there was a packed lunch and two
water bottles that smelled like gasoline
huh all of her clothes and shoes had
tags cut off just like Somerton man okay
so so these people found this body and
they took it for an autopsy they said
that she died from a combination of
burns from the fire and from carbon
monoxide poisoning they also found a
bunch of sleeping pills in her system
although that's not what had killed her
so when they tried to identify her they
did they did dental work on her and they
said that the dental work was of a type
particular to a South American
dentist because I guess they can tell
that because they use different methods
in different countries I guess now some
some reports say that her fingerprints
had been sanded off and I'm not sure
that might be a mistranslation from the
original norwegian article because i saw
in wikipedia that someone who spoke
Norwegian and English said that actually
the original Norwegian article said that
just all the fingerprints were wiped off
of everything like wiped off all her
stuff so I don't like a lot of that
sounds more like yeah so a lot of
reports say that her fingerprints were
filed off but I'm not sure if that's the
case now I would attract too much of
attention it was right right right so I
don't know that's that's probably a
mistranslation now after they had drawn
sketches of her not very good ones you
can look at pictures they're not very
good sketches but was her face burnt
maybe they weren't sure what her face
looked like um yeah it could have been
it's I don't know I really say yeah
because she was like partially burned I
don't know how badly she was burned but
after they published the sketches of her
a hiker came forward and he said that
earlier that day the day she had been
found dead he had seen a woman up in the
valley
and he said he noticed her because she
was wearing kind of elegant clothes not
like hiking clothes and he said also she
seemed to be scared and there were two
big Mediterranean looking men following
her and he said he passed her and she
kind of opened her mouth at him like she
was gonna say something but then she
didn't and then she kept on going now
like I said this is just this guy saying
that he saw her so I don't know if
that's sure or not but they they
interviewed a shitload of people and it
came to light that now I think just like
in the Somerton Man case they also found
uh they also found a suitcase of hers in
a train station in a storage locker in
that suitcase
they found nine
passports with nine different identities
pictures at her picture was on him yeah
and a bunch of clothes all with the tags
removed they all looked like Italian
style
they also found a bunch of wigs non
prescription eyeglasses yeah and a bunch
of silver spoons like the ones they
found at the camp but these ones had
monograms on them and inside the lining
of the suitcase they found 500 German
marks and 130 Norwegian crowns now from
witness accounts after they published
the sketches a lot of witnesses
identified her now she had been moving
all around Europe kind of the last
months before she died because a lot of
people saw her at various hotels and she
always checked into hotels under
different names a couple people said she
seemed watchful or suspicious at one
place they one guest had seen her on a
payphone and she had been speaking in
German and she said I'm coming soon to
someone on the other end of the line
that was the day before she died and so
there is also they also in her suitcase
they found a notebook and it also had a
code in it like a numerical code now
some of that has been cracked and they
think that it was her itinerary so they
kind of have an idea of where she went
from about the end of March 1972 to no
end of November when she died where'd
she go she went there her first place
she went she went from Geneva to Oslo
stayed in Oslo using the name Genevieve
Lancia then she went to a place called
God's to vengers event see I don't I
don't know I'm not Norwegian and took a
boat to Bergen stayed the night at a
hotel using the name at Claudia tilt and
she was still using that name the next
week then she went to Hamburg and then
she went to Stockholm then she went to
Paris
then she went to Bergen Norway she was
always using different names because
people I people remember her at the
hotels and stuff like that but and they
had her name in the register but she
always had different names but all these
names correspond to names that were on
her passports the passports that they
I'm gonna say right now something said
he's Germans by yes see that's what a
lot of people thought too now see this
is another they said according to
witnesses that had seen her in various
hotels over the months prior to her
death she spoke at least four languages
including English German Flemish and
French they couldn't figure out where
her accent was from although they did
track down in her suitcase they found a
postcard from an Italian photographer
and they tracked that guy down and he
said he said well I didn't know much
about her I took her out to dinner one
night she said she was from South Africa
and that she was an antiques dealer and
that's what she wrote on by some of her
yeah and they said pretty much the only
distinctive thing about her they figured
her clothes were probably Italian
because they were that kind of style at
the time they said she liked porridge
with milk
cuz that's she ordered that at every
hotel sounds like a he's German for some
reason yeah porridge with milk so uh but
they you know they put sketches of her
and [ __ ] like that like all over and she
has never been identified and she is
she's now in an unmarked grave in Norway
and so 45 years been 45 years and they
still don't know who she was um so I
think she's been East German spy
probably a spy and she was getting ready
to defect and East Germans was with East
Germany was a satellite of Russia those
Mediterranean men that they're talking
about were Russians the Russians killed
her before she defected that's what I
think happened they they made it look
like tried to make it look like a
suicide give her a bunch of pills yeah
scattered him around scat him around and
then probably put her head over the fire
and threw a blanket over her over her
head and the fire and trying to get
killed her with carbon monoxide
poisoning they tried to make it look
a roughshod suicide yeah that's probably
although honestly if I was gonna make
something look like a suicide I don't
think I would
it sounds pretty it sounds pretty messy
the way they did it yeah they may have
been sending a message yeah you got that
exactly
hey Pratt could have done it a lot
better now but they want they wanted
other possible defectors or other
intelligence agencies to know that they
did it hey don't do this Yeah right
something like that now is it possible
that she was not a spy but she was like
some kind of master criminal like an
international smuggler or something like
that
no cuz nobody would wanted her dead
think about I don't think no they just
would have arrested her whoever wanted
her whatever arrested yeah honestly I do
think she was a spy spy she's gonna be a
spy sure and it's so weird the way she
was a spy she was gonna defect she knew
something that she had too much
information they couldn't let her
defects they'd kill her yeah it's super
weird because I mean it's weird that
there are so many parallels between her
case and the Somerton man case yeah you
know with this with the [ __ ] of the
suitcase and the codes and the there's a
lot a lot of that they're put in
suitcases in storage lockers at bus
stations and at train stations that's
pretty common that comes up a lot yeah I
guess I guess these operatives remove
the labels from their clothes yeah that
way if they're ever arrested that their
identities can't be defragged it hinders
investigations they just take a label
even that would be a debt that would be
a giveaway though if you know how many
labels that's what I mean it's like
that's that's what kills me it's like
it's more suspicious to take them off
and might they might have been using an
older doctrine right because nowadays
and like I said even in 1948 in the
Somerton man case they still knew that
the clothes were American from the way
the stitching was this is a different
even though the labels were gone this is
a different time I mean now everything's
from China or somewhere in the Far East
you know I mean so you didn't have to
remove the labels but back in those days
if maybe it was yeah things were more
distinctive where the right where they
were made so it was just safer overall
to just remove the labels yeah I guess
so that way it could be deniable
possible deniability although the weird
thing about like I said the weird thing
about this Somerton man case was that
yeah the labels were removed except for
there was actually one laundry tag that
said T keen on it k EAN but then on the
back of his tie it's at T keen ke a and
E so they don't know if that was
actually his name or if they did that to
throw authorities off a bit identity
might have been his cover cover name yes
because they couldn't find anyone who
his laundry right back in those days
people dry cleaned and they did the
laundry a lot you know I mean people
there I guess washers and dryers and
your houses weren't as common back then
yeah yes I started to think so you had
to kind of have some name to tell the
longer to tell the laundry people cuz
they couldn't find anybody at that name
regardless but the case of the is doll
woman like I said they they pretty much
cracked the code that was in her
notebook it was just an itinerary but
they still have no idea who she was why
she was killed they don't know what a
real name was even because she was going
by nine different ones actually in the
70s they did have a lot of laundry in
the house but maybe they didn't have
houses these are agents and they're
moving yeah obviously she had been
moving around they have to use
professional laundry services maybe
laundry mats weren't were hard to find
so they would just they were living in
hotels yeah but and actually I don't
know like Somerton man is actually a
pretty famous case but it's all woman
not so well known although it's very
very famous in Norway's like their most
famous unsolved murder we don't know who
they are but they do they were the see
the first time you said that I thought
you meant we don't know who they are but
they knew they liked they knew who they
were themselves are they like well yeah
the intelligence agencies knew who they
were and I would imagine the cops had an
inkling that these were Intel agents
well that's another thing that I forgot
to mention was that it is doll woman
case um I think the hiker let me check
this but I think the hiker
they called and said that he had seen
her alive he said that the cop told him
don't worry about it it's never gonna be
solved
yeah he said that's what the cop said
sure like I said it's just his word but
that's what he said yeah the cops knew
so the cops must have known it well the
cops know what a crime looks like yeah
they know their crime and ahead yeah
yeah I mean when these kind of people
these are not organized criminals doing
hits these are government's doing hits
yeah so yeah you never saw those I
wonder what she did those are the she
had information she was gonna defect she
was screwing dudes and finding that
fighting [ __ ] out and then you know she
was gonna run with the information rat
and go after the other side so they
killed her yeah somebody did one side of
the other I would not want to be a spy
most of it isn't like that no I know no
I'm not taking any chances
I think those are exceptions those are
exceptions to the rules it's called wet
work so you know what I mean wet works
is killing somebody first yeah but that
was mostly a Cold War thing yeah it's
it's my understanding based on you know
conversations with people yeah it's it's
my understanding that it spies if you
want to call them spies killing each
other as a last resort
that's not normal yeah okay I don't want
to end up sent wearing some fire with
all my teeth knocked out or whatever
yeah creepy so anyway um I guess that's
probably oh yeah [ __ ] we're going up on
an hour all right
yeah well I'm probably more than that
right now that I'm so whatever I don't
know
so you're you what you're mumbling
mumbling okay at least we finally got
this dawn God uh poor tom was so sick
yesterday we were gonna record this yes
yeah we honestly pee
do you feel like that well you can go
take a nap if you want to it's all right
now yeah you've got a good time old man
now
oh just old man alright let's wrap it up
alright alright so we hope you enjoyed
the show about spooky spy [ __ ] and if
you liked the show then subscribe to our
youtube channel which is called 13
o'clock podcast also like us on Facebook
and follow us on Twitter and all that
other junk yeah if you like spy stuff
check out the check out our angry gay
Pope video that we put up the other day
enter by interpolating Scientology
that's that's a cool show too yeah cuz
man that shit's unbelievable yeah
Scientology [ __ ] Scientology's off if I
didn't know if I didn't know that that
[ __ ] really happened cuz I used to work
for them and I knew some of them and
[ __ ] like that
and if I didn't know that all that [ __ ]
was true I would think somebody just
made that [ __ ] and they have their own
spy agency called OSA that's right they
have special Affairs even though they're
kind of Keystone Cops about it honestly
well who knows they hire a lot of pies
anyway let's wrap it up alright alright
so so anyway to subscribe and like all
our [ __ ] you know how it goes and then
that'll do it
bye bye bye
you